hi Internet my name is Cameron chambers
and this is cameras never seen today I
am watching demolition man demolition
man was one of my favorite reviews to be
a part of for nostalgia critic so I'm
pretty excited to watch the film that I
had so much fun you know making fun of
okay on Twitter I said give me those
demolition man predictions for the next
20 minutes also here's a skateboarding
cat in deep socks Thanks it's really
cute it's really cute cat so here we go
you know black demolition man let's do
it yeah that has the same kind of cheesy
fun that Judge Dredd had but honestly
Sylvester Stallone was so much better
this like way better way more likeable
the story was hilarious is always funny
to see how the future is portrayed
specially like from you know 20 years
ago I love one of Stallone's first lines
send maniacs to catch one I identify
with that I'm coming for you Ike
so in the beginning of the movie you see
that Wesley Snipes is the bad guy and
Sylvester Stallone is the good cop and
Wesley Snipes frames Sylvester Stallone
but Wesley Snipes is wearing bill pants
the whole time bill was first been there
since the beginning young Sylvester
Stallone is sentenced to 70 years in
kairo kairo genic is that that's the
word pyrogenic prison where they freeze
you that's just some fallout for shit
y'all Salam is placed in its cryogenic
gel in a very arousing seed strangely
enough I can't believe that that is like
a sentencing I want to be placed in that
gel and awoken in 70 years the future is
going to be awesome they're gonna have a
cure for diabetes cats are going to be
able to talk fallout 5 will finally be
out I ranked those in order by the way
so it's slash or do you see the future
and it's a hilarious and awesome you see
Sandra Bullock who the treasurer you see
mother
Rob Schneider fuck thankfully Rob
Schneider is not in this movie very much
he's like the receptionist at the police
station and he's got two or three or
four lines not many and he didn't get on
my nerves like I thought that he would
also he didn't do any weird mouth open
anything
so that's fresh Sanders character is
she's a young cop and she's longing for
action in his peaceful world she's got a
Lethal Weapon 3 poster on her wall
from the past she's got skinny nineties
eyebrows and I love her and no I've not
seen Lethal Weapon 3 or 2 Wesley Snipes
character Phoenix is defrosted comes out
and killed a bunch of people and they
haven't had a murder in like 23 years
honestly Rob Schneider had a great line
here we're police officers we are trying
to handle violence like this they decide
the only person that can take out
Phoenix is Sylvester Stallone's
character so they unfreeze demolition
man and love his wake up scene he find
out that like bean and alcohol and meat
is illegal and I take back what I said
about wanting to be frozen and sent to
the future can't do it no thank you
I refuse that life and then I wrote oh
my god that's three see what the hell
I'm gonna give you my ideas on what I
think the three seashells is and means
okay now I am okay first idea you know
those really tacky souvenirs soaps that
you get when you visit a beach town that
are shaped like seashells maybe they're
just little soaps and you just like
definitely caress your bottom with them
alright first idea is done
don't great come at me second idea maybe
since it's the future and so many things
are different maybe seashells are
different now too
maybe they're like sea sponges in the
shape of shells so maybe they're just
cute little sponges that you delicately
crisp your bottom lip again done nails
it boom all right number three ah maybe
there's a live animal in the sea show
like a little clam or an oyster and he
just like spits water at you and
delicately spits leather on your bottom
after you go to the bathroom boom
crushing it Sandra has this incredible
line about the way that Stallone
interacted with somebody and it's so
funny she said if you read my study
you'd know this is how insecure hetero
males used to bond Oh fire I love the
bad word violations that go off every
few seconds when Sylvester Stallone's is
a bad word verbal morality that also the
commercials oldies radio station is
hilarious but the more funny part of
that I think is that radio still exists
in 2032
so Sylvester and Sandra go to a museum
which is the only place that they have
guns anymore well a museum in this couch
yeah and they're looking for Phoenix in
this portion of the movie there were
just a lot of funny things with the
future the Pope looking guy writes them
to Taco Bell for saving him I wonder if
they have the Doritos locos taco because
if not again not a future I want to be a
part of but it's revealed that Taco Bell
is the only restaurant left there's like
valet parking and their champagne a
piano player change your mind again
want to be in his future Sandra reveals
that fortune eager had been president in
the past and Sylvester Stallone is like
pissed and it's so funny and somehow
very topical and that is all I will say
on that matter so on the way home from
their delightful Taco Bell dinner Salone
and Sandra are talking about his
daughter who is still alive and he's
worried about seeing her again and I
really wish that this they went with the
story like that Sandra was his daughter
and and that she wasn't going to be like
his love interest and only halfway
through the film at this point but I was
pretty sure that's where that was going
and then the sex scene happens which is
so weird so funny surprisingly a
tasteful sex scene fluid transfer is
outlawed and that makes sense if people
called sex fluid transfer I'd want it to
be outlawed as well this is where you
find out that the Pope looking guy needs
Wesley Snipes Phoenix to take out the
leader of the scratch the leader of the
scraps alone decides to just take
matters into his own hands and he goes
down to address the scraps and to find
Phoenix and he ends up having a rat
burger and a beer it's really funny then
after that it's just a giant action
sequence Wesley Snipes Phoenix goes and
kills the Pope looking guy Sandra
Bullock good God above she'd be took all
these people and she killed someone
she totally proves that she's an awesome
fighter and then before they go in to
take on Phoenix so that's just alone
like shocks her and and she passes out
because he's like I did it for your own
good the wall I know you just proved
yourself you're a good fighter and that
you'll do whatever to keep ourselves
safe but you know a guy did this oh my
yells some of good like macho do but
Stallone takes out Phoenix and everyone
is saved and it was a really cool fights
really great way to take him out I loved
the end the freezing but again at the
end
Sandra's like so I thought we were a
team bra he's like yeah we were was for
your own good she's like I don't think
that's not really nah I don't agree and
then he like twirls her around and
kisses her it's like oh cool
solves everything no one it didn't
bother me a ton but it was just like why
that why'd it have to go that way but I
did love this movie
I predict that the predictions will be
full of three seashells thing you'll
want a prequel movie that chronicles the
franchise wars in all their gory details
yes how did Taco Bell win it weren't all
of their soldiers sick all the time
robbed a it was Taco Bell
you'll find it weird they predicted it
right that Arnold Schwarzenegger would
go into politics yes also three
seashells what the fuck yes seems like a
lot of you really wanted to know the
fuss of three seashells
same-same when you see the big guy from
beetlejuice all you can picture is him
reading from the book of the recently
deceased I get that reference now Bing
Stallone clearly wins the penis game yes
I finally get that reference but Doug
and Rob make at the studio all the time
prudish I don't care about demolition
man but yeah I had such a good time with
this movie I thought Wesley sense was
awesome
Stallone was so much better this than an
Judge Dredd Sandra Bullock a treasure
Cherisher protect her at all cost
next week I might watch an Edgar Wright
film I love to baby driver so much and
I'm still on that hype train from that
look out on my Twitter for more
predictions and I'll probably be putting
up a pole sometime this week about what
my next move you should be thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys next
week
bye what the
[Music]
[Applause]
you